et
[Musique]
la grande expédition des forces
musicales shadoks sur la terre a échoué
comme ceux qui les ont précédés les
vaillants shadow knott ont fini au
garde-manger
[Musique]
mais depuis le temps qu'ils ont des sens
autun et qui l'on descendait de la lune
et depuis ton qu'ils finissaient tous au
garde manger gégène avec ses châteaux
prisonniers commencé à avoir des
problèmes de rangement chez lui c'en
était pratiquement infestés il avait
fallu en mettre aussi dans les
baignoires les armoires les lavabos et
les tuyaux tout était plein de shadow ça
commençait à se détraquer c'est depuis
ce temps là d'ailleurs que sur la terre
quand quelque chose tombe en panne les
gens disent à doit y avoir encore un
shadok de coincer là dedans
[Musique]
et
comme il ne pouvait pas venir à bout des
shadoks note pour le moment et que
certains même commencé à se gâter il
avait demandé conseil à ses amis les gy
be le mieux
il pensait c'était au cours de les
mettre à paître dont les champs mais ces
bêtes là il s'est dit c'est bien du
souci parce que je ne sais pas si vous
avez quelques fois essayé de faire
paître des shadoks l'aude mais ça paie
pas ou quand ça pète ça paie ma vous les
mettez dans un champ et bien ça mange
l'herbe et puis ça mange le chant ou
bien ça mange n'importe quoi ce qui les
rend très rapidement impropre à la
consommation
comme il le mettait aucune bonne volonté
pour être mangeable frais il fallut bien
trouver un moyen pour les conserver avec
les plus dodue l'egypte y firent du pâté
des plus maigres salé et fumé faisaient
des shadows pso donc comptablement
percée de ci de là de trous donner un
assez bon fromage mais même après tout
cela il me restait encore énormément
cela l'egypte ils les emmenèrent chez
eux en disant qu'il s'en occuperait
personnellement
[Musique]